this person claimed that Elon Musk
wanting to buy Twitter was ultimately
just about quote white power
they call for the destruction of statues
of Jesus Christ suggesting they depicted
white supremacy racist propaganda and
oppression this person has white male on
their birth certificate however he
claims there's more the story who is
this person I uh named the well-known
talcum X Sean King wow we have the exact
same AKA Max on the space off we will
find out which modern day Gladiator
knows more about the topic of the day
one that will inevitably be a pillar of
whatever Democrat runs for president in
2024 racism buckle up because it's not
just about race it's about the people
who hustle it today we have Christopher
Ruffo author of America's cultural
revolution how the radical left
conquered everything taking on Michael
Knowles now between these two gentlemen
it may be impossible to know who gets
accused of racism more often but we will
find out who knows more about the people
who peddle it this is Face-Off race
Hustler
[Music]
foreign
confident today I'm feeling very good
and I'm feeling especially good because
I am by far the darkest man on this
panel even though Chris and I have the
same ethnic background for some reason I
am at least four or to seven Shades
Darker so I'm feeling good about my
chances I'm feeling much better about
your chances now and Christopher what
did you do to prepare for this episode
uh absolutely nothing I just have this
Serene and Zen calm of a master of of
race hustling knowledge feeling quite
good quite confident right now gentlemen
you each have 30 seconds to give your
answer
this is question number one this person
said that if she could identify as
anything she wanted she would be a
pan-african pro-black bisexual mother
activist artist but trans black is just
easier
she changed her legal name to nikichi
Amare Diallo and finally this person
also has and only fan site
who is this race Hustler oh
like Christopher wrote that down pretty
quick I was there all right Knowles what
do you got I'm gonna guess listen unlike
you Ben I don't subscribe to hers or any
other only fans website but I'm gonna
guess Rachel dollazole
Christopher
uh yep I'm also here with Rachel
dollazal I think she has a kind of foot
fetish site if I remember correctly
that's what I read that I visited it
that is correct visited but uh didn't
but Ben Ben said it was like uh I
brought this up to him some time ago and
Ben said that it was a fuller only fan
site all right next to subscribe just to
find out the truth I I do not recommend
that I do not remember that all number
two this person began preaching at the
age of four and was an ordained
Pentecostal minister at age 10. this
person also delivered Michael Jackson's
eulogy Trump called this person a con
man and recently this person gave Jordan
Neely's eulogy this person also spells
respect r-e-s-p-i-c-t
all right we'll let Mr rufo go first
I'm going uh with Al Sharpton Michael
the very reverend in quotes Al Sharpton
when he's not starting race riots in
Crown Heights he is shaking down
corporations and giving eulogies at
random people's funerals
gentlemen we are batting a thousand two
two so in the words of my late friend
Aretha Franklin show some
r-e-s-p-i-c-t did you guys have any idea
you'd start off this good yes yes
absolutely a hundred percent yeah all
right number three this person claimed
that Elon Musk wanting to buy Twitter
was ultimately just about quote white
power
they call for the destruction of statues
of Jesus Christ suggesting they depicted
white supremacy racist propaganda and
oppression this person has white male on
their birth certificate however he
claims there's more the story who is
this person
you guys are flying through this this
has made him harder all right Mike what
do you got I uh named the well-known
talcum X Sean King
all right Chris wow we have the exact
same thing AKA Taco Max
that's amazing yeah I think we'll give a
bonus point I think we're here we're
right here you know Chris and I are
actually so close we can almost finish
each other's sandwiches never mind never
mind all right number four
this person has been called the quote
black America's attorney general they
had their own Netflix original about
them this person also took part in a
lawsuit against Ed Sheeran which claimed
that Sharon's song Thinking Out Loud
from 2014 was actually stolen from
Marvin Gaye's let's get it on this
person claimed the original gay song was
actually quote a Cornerstone in the
American Experience
you know freedom statue of liberty Let's
Get It On
with the title black America's attorney
general is
metaphorical literal is it or literal
it's a nickname then he has well I know
it's a nickname that he had I'm saying
like is the guy an attorney general no
you're not going to tell me no he's
definitely not all right well I'm gonna
take my anther off yeah I was thinking
the same thing this one is hard this one
is tough now remember the shearing case
but I don't know
10 seconds
all right
okay I think I got it
we'll see if you got it Michael
I'm gonna say uh
Johnny Cochran's ghost
I like it I wish I could take it
Christopher what do you got yeah I
thought it was Eric Holder then you said
it was not literal so I'm going with the
only other attorney that seems to be
everywhere uh Ben Crump it is Ben Crump
oh shoot there it is
all right all right next up this person
ran for U.S president twice but has
never held elected office they founded
the rainbow push Coalition and while
caught on a hot mic this person said
that he wanted to quote cut Barack
Obama's nuts out
who is this person well that doesn't
narrow it down you know that but I think
I still know
oh man my first guess was Ben Shapiro
all right what do you got Christopher
uh this is Jesse Jackson the one and
only
um that was uh uh quite a quote Still
Still hits me to this day
this one just Jesse Jackson also ties in
with one of Chris's other uh minor
interests which would be uh the complete
collapse of Education because it was
Jesse Jackson who led the march at
Stanford where he said hey hey ho ho
Western Civ has got to go we're gonna go
on to the next question
all right next up this person has said
quote black people are apparently
responsible for calming the fears of
violent cops in the way women are
supposedly responsible for calming the
sexual desires of male rapists this
person was born with the last name
Rogers but chose a new last name after
he got married looks like Christopher
knows already oh shoot
this person is also the author of how to
be an anti-racist oh one of Michael's
favorite books
the other Mr X let's find out Abram X
candy
right yeah right my friend man
he even makes candy is correct my guy we
are still tied up this is gonna go down
to the wire Chris when was the last time
you you spoke with your pal uh Ibrahim
I've been blocked you know even had a
couple difficult uh exchanges with me in
the in the past and um and just just
couldn't handle it I think and uh you
know he he blocked me but I'm I'm hoping
that with time there's some forgiveness
or reconciliation and we can be friends
again that'd be nice in the meantime
though it's just clear anti-italian
discrimination that's right you're
blocked too I take it yeah yeah that's
right I gotta do something better I'm
still I'm not blocked by this guy yet I
gotta get more active on Twitter or X
sorry x x all right next named after
everything
all right here we go despite living in
poverty her entire childhood and young
adulthood she believed she had always
benefited from white privilege
she stated that quote if you're a white
person you are racist pure and simple
and this person is also the best-selling
author of white fragility
I think you guys can both show at the
same time for this one yeah
unfortunately for both Knowles and for
me she's also an Italian Robin D'Angelo
Barry said she does our people real
dirty Robin X D'Angelo as a result of
being born and raised as a white person
in this culture I have a racist
worldview I have deep racist biases all
right here we go this person was adopted
at five weeks old and was raised by
white parents he went on to maintain a
4.0 GPA throughout his college career
while playing football he had a very
controversial career in the NFL and
reportedly lost a recent job opportunity
to play with the Ravens and it was
allegedly because he lost it when his
girlfriend compared the team's owner to
a slave owner
which is probably true because he later
starred in a documentary that compared
slavery to the NFL draft who is this
person
I think we got this one right it's just
calling Kaepernick Colin X Kaepernick
yep but yeah they're still the last name
writer I'm not gonna take it you know
that's right I think it is
of the vowels in his last name all right
next up
this person gave us the immortal tweet
quote rooting for the Celtics is like
saying Hitler was a victim
and while working at ESPN this person
tweeted you're a racist if you vote for
Trump even though their mother didn't
fact vote for Trump this person claimed
that the reaction to Carly Russell the
black woman who faked getting kidnapped
was racist and that the Public's
reaction would quote not be the same if
she had been White
they were also cast in the 2022 Showtime
docu-series everything's gonna be all
white
who is this person
you said this is a manner this is a
woman woman okay see how I put that bit
of information out of him I did it so
casually he didn't even notice
a woman oh
oh I know I think I know this chick I I
don't think I've watched more than 30
seconds of ESPN in my entire life so I
don't know her name
maybe I can link blank Morse code the
answer like if you would yeah yeah if
you wouldn't mind
all right Christopher what do you got
so I just had put uh the ESPN lady who
constantly complains and then I think it
triggered something and am I correct in
saying is Jameel or Jamila Hill Michael
is that right I it's a it is
unbelievable what a wavelength Chris and
I are on because I too wrote that chick
from CNN but I forgot then I don't know
I mean I I know the name jamily Hill but
I don't know if that's the same person I
either it is Jamel Hill wow wow boom
there you go Jamel Hill all right and
Michael actually write Jamel Hill though
or did you say no I just wrote that
chick from CNN yeah I don't know if we
can take it it was substantial yeah yeah
I think Chris gets it devastating yeah
devastating that our answers were almost
the same rufo have one currently 10-9
rufo is up one yikes man yikes here we
go I gotta I gotta come back
there we go and it might happen starting
now this person is a Hollywood Starlet
in an interview this person openly
admitted that they quote hate blonde
white women
this person led the charge of boycotting
the Oscars with the hashtag Oscar so
white
is a Hollywood Starlet okay
um
there were like three black actresses in
Hollywood I don't
you know maybe she has a point because I
actually can't name them any black
actresses uh true
[Music]
if it helps she hates white women that
are blonde that does not narrow it down
this is a Hollywood star the only one I
can think of is Lupita Nyong'o who's
like normal so I don't it's not she
seems fine yeah
all right well
I'm gonna say
all right well I got something all right
what do you got Michael uh Sydney
Poitier
for sure
I I just put the Will Smith's ex-wife
oh it's Will Smith right
Jada Pinkett Smith
hair on white women just triggers me is
it it is her though yeah we at least
divorced I don't think so unfortunately
for him
I think that counts in my favor I just
thought they were divorced but it's the
right lady can we please doc Chris for
saying X I would give him the point but
if the judges want to steal it from him
please do I really want to give
Christopher a point but I mean they're
screaming my ear that absolutely not is
coming through here really wow okay yeah
there we go baby that's a rigged
election this is hegemony here you want
to talk about cultural hegemony that's
right okay all right next up this
person's birth name was Ronald McKinley
Everett they were convicted of felony
assault torture and false imprisonment
of women but he did not go to prison
this person declared that Christianity
is a quote white religion and that black
people should shun it which makes sense
because this person also created Kwanzaa
oh you know this one
I don't know the guy's name
you're you will recognize it when I say
it you will you've heard this name many
times it's the it's the funniest it's
kind of sad because he tortured women
and like hit him on the head with
toasters and like did I mean he did like
insane branded them and everything but
yeah shall we yeah should we do it yeah
take it okay as I completely butcher
this name Melana karenga oh here we go
Moana
Kalinga all right so does that tie it up
after you cheated Chris Evans last Point
yeah I feel like you guys have shuttered
the windows and there's people bringing
in Balance
hold on there was a pipe that just burst
pipe in our studio yeah
all right next up this person is another
Hollywood celebrity
they also called white people and Jews
quote evil Savages closer to animals
according to the LA Times even after
being recently fired they reportedly
still make over 100 million dollars per
year
who is this person
that guy makes a hundred
that makes 100 million dollars a year
according to the LA Times wow
I mean I only you'll you'll remember
this also if it doesn't occur to you
before the time runs up I can't
pronounce this name
oh wait maybe I'm wrong
I can't pronounce the name hold on hold
on read The Prompt again because now
you're making me question my answer
okay
uh according to the LA okay this person
is another Hollywood celebrity yeah they
also called white people and Jews evil
Savages closer to animals and according
to the LA Times even after being
recently fired reportedly they still
make over 100 million dollars okay I'm
sticking by my answer all right all
right Chris what do you got I have no
idea zero no idea I'm gonna say Nick
Cannon
yeah Nick Cannon what makes you think
that's hard to I'll say I can pronounce
oh you're saying you can print oh yeah
that's an easy name man yeah so there
you know I'm not there's a story about
that they're the ones that are actually
closer to animals they're the ones that
are actually the true Savages but I'm
not gonna say 100 million dollars a year
this is the guy that just has many
children right yes what does he actually
do I never quite understood what he
actually does he was on Nickelodeon in
like 1997 and somehow which is a life
curse yes
or or or something horrible happening to
you yeah yeah the story though about why
he thinks that I'm not going to say it
because it might pertain to a later
question uh depending on how many race
Hustlers you've got but it is
all right I'll save it to the end we'll
see if the name doesn't come up then
maybe we'll get into it Michael is the
constant tease all right here we go wow
this person is a former NFL Super Bowl
champion
he is the author of the book quote
things that make white people
uncomfortable and in 2017 after inciting
Mass outrage over his claims of racist
Las Vegas Police threatening to quote
blow his head off he was caught
completely lying about all the details
when the body footage was released who
is this person
it's easy all right Michael Joe name
obviously
I got O.J Simpson I almost wrote OJ the
correct answer is Michael Bennett what
did he say to you when he had the gun to
your head we'll blow your head off if
you move
here he won the Super Bowl with the
Seattle Seahawks didn't he run for
president 2016 wasn't he like one of the
Democrats running
[Music]
what's the score now
11 10 with Michael up now
so can you give Chris his point back
I mean if
it's ex-wife like but yes no don't look
don't do it on my account I was
projecting a desire I was projecting a
desire yeah
I know you know who it was though that's
true I mean you're right I know you
could see her in your head obviously
yeah we will do the Half Point all right
here we go last question okay despite it
first glance looking white has the
driven snow this person claimed they
were a native American now not one but
two college applications
um they took An ancestry quiz an attempt
to show off their racial street cred and
this person is the acclaimed author of
the Native American cookbook pow-wow
ciao
all right Chris what are you up
none other than a chief Liz Warren
liawatha Chief spreading Bowl
the Massachusetts senatrix Elizabeth
Warren that is correct gentlemen my
Papaw had high cheekbones like all of
the Indians do Pocahontas Pocahontas
that's right so you know the story so
that's all the questions that is all the
questions so you know the story The
thing about Nick Cannon that's crazy is
he got that idea from this crazy CUNY
Professor named Jeffries it was Lionel
Jeffries or Leonard Jeffries who had
this idea that white people are the
people of the ice and black people are
the people yes so he developed this
whole theory that Nick Cannon
articulated and that guy's nephew is now
the Democrat leader in the House of
Representatives Hakeem Jeffries wow
that's right yeah now this is a
gentleman's game and usually when it
comes down this close there are two
bonus questions and if the person is the
winner as Michael is currently by half a
point okay you can give an opportunity
to have a tiebreaker still on the final
question if you'd like to it's up to you
Michael I I'd be willing in my great
magnanimity my my greatness of soul I
would be willing to extend that to Chris
and I will accept all right
it's coming down the wire boys let's do
it all right what is the name of the
Native American activist Marlon Brando
asked to speak when he declined his
Oscar for The Godfather
oh what is that woman's name
oh
I'm trying to get it
um
oh
she's a white lady too she's not a
Native American yeah uh Snow Snow White
yeah yeah
I'm sweating this is getting intense
oh
all right at least one half a point here
it's something Little Feather right yeah
I got Little Feather it is a little
finger little finger what's your first
name Shailene
okay there we go yeah Little Feather but
her real name is Mexican or something
she's just like a regular like white
Hispanic yeah I don't I don't have it on
my cards currently but there is a bonus
bonus question here okay and this is for
George Zimmerman of her time
what tribe did she claim to be from
I'll be really impressed to be the one
you know this one
all right what do you got I said the
Cheyenne
I said the Oneida
it is the little-known White Mountain
Apache the White Mountain Apache she
kind of tips her head a little bit there
you know even her Native American tribe
was white that's amazing all right well
since you guys tied Michael you are the
champion
well done really good stuff thank you
I'm glad that Davies didn't even need to
cheat to deprive uh Chris of his
well-earned Half Point uh that's really
pretty upset at Will Smith at this point
I will say if he had only divorced that
lady as I think he was well within his
right too you know what could have been
the one that came out on top I'll tell
you though I you know obviously
Catholics we have this very strong view
of marriage like it's indissoluable and
but sometimes Catholics don't don't live
up to that Will Smith I don't think the
guy's Catholic but he is living up to
truly super human virtue by staying with
that horrible horrible woman yeah yeah
that's true although I think you know if
you if you ask the pope there could be
special dispensation given the
circumstances yeah yeah I haven't spoken
to the Holy Father about it that's
great all right Christopher if you would
do you mind giving us a 30 second Pitch
of why people should tune into the
Michael show I will you have to tune in
to Michael Knowles not only for his uh
handsome appearance uh his incredibly
gracious demeanor and His stunning and
sparkling intellect uh but because uh he
has Supreme knowledge of the race
Hustlers of American history and so tune
in Michael and it'll show every day on
The Daily wire
that was so beautiful by the way though
you can't just tune in because I'm so
handsome that's fine you don't need any
of the other stuff it's totally
uh by the way I have this is going to be
a little tease
do you know what book I received in the
mail just yesterday
I received I received a certain book
from a certain author who might be on
this panel
Memoirs of Ben Davies
[Music]
no I'm joking I received your book Chris
and I'm going to be reviewing it in an
upcoming very highly sought after and
respected publication so I I look
forward to it and given your excellent
performance on today's show I now expect
it to be a very good book thank you so
much well there you have it if you
haven't already stop what you're doing
and get your copy of Christopher rufo's
new book America's cultural revolution
how the radical left conquered
everything which you can get everywhere
books are sold and please write in the
comments section and let us know who
you'd like to see and what topic to
cover in the next episode of Face Off